hey guys greg alba here john here so i
literally just asked john why we do a
video called what we'd like to see from
superhero movies and he said yeah sure
because we just saw a video from
longtime subscriber nerdy hero that kind
of sparked some thoughts in my brain his
video was fifty shades of Joker Marines
up like the song sorc sent my style of
the Fifty Shades trailer and put it over
like a that would be a love story of
Joker and Harley Quinn after watching
that it didn't remind me of things I
would like to see in superhero films
expand in terms of their whole universe
you know like I like what Star Wars is
doing in terms of its not a comic book
movie but in terms of them doing like
Road one and the han solo movie like
these films are not expected to be as
massive hits as you know the linear
franchise of episode 1 2 3 through 9 but
they're their own kind of spin-offs
they're not low budget but they're not
as big budget but there but hopefully
anyway they're not all expected to be
the exact same tone and the exact same
style as a Star Wars film their
broadening out their spectrum and their
palette and trying new stories in that
universe and I don't expect help DC or
marvel to start doing that just yet
although I would like them eventually to
start doing stuff like that yeah like
another during a Harley Quinn movie but
it would be cool to just see like I
don't know like a 50 million dollar
movie of like Harley Quinn and the Joker
and I feel like they could do that like
people put together great fan fiction
films of [ __ ] on YouTube all the time
and I think like man if they got like a
50 million dollar budget which is not a
lot for a lot of these big studio films
they can make something totally amazing
yeah take those characters make a
totally different kind of movie and like
yeah there cuz some of my favorite
comics that I've ever read our sort of
strange genre bender comic books are
like else world style comic books where
it's like alternate universe stuff and I
feel like that is a place where
superhero films could be totally
revitalized you get like really
interesting
filmmakers and let them do their stuff I
know it's kind of wrote to talk about no
one's Batman films but that's kind of
like what made those specials the first
one he took that and he sort of did it
in his style what I feel like is is that
these movies they all feel like I have
to honor one world and I feel like your
comic books you don't have to honor just
the one specific world you're doing yes
you don't have fun yeah you don't have
to do your own DC just this one because
that's actually you're actually limiting
your capacity for what you can
accomplish with just the one like the
phase one a Marvel the phase two and
they all have to be connected in a
certain way like I think that why not
make a live-action Batman year one movie
yes and you don't have to make it Ben
Affleck's Batman that story is primarily
about lieutenant Gordon or Commissioner
Gordon James Gordon that one's mainly
about Jim Gordon and I feel like yeah
you could do like a 50 you could get
like I don't know darren aronofsky
someone who's into like neo new arm yeah
yeah or a Nicholas like if you wanted to
get like you're Nicholas winning roughen
to step in and do like a superhero movie
allow him to adapt like here adapt this
graphic novel right here it doesn't have
to be part of the DC huge linear canon
it could just be like we're gonna just
do this special movie or like even if
they did the killing joke and they just
had another actor play The Joker they
didn't have to get Jared Leto to do is
what would make your the storylines I
feel in the one world they have
established is keeping the same actors
on board whatever similar tone and style
in some capacity their graphic novels so
you have so many different kinds of
interpretations iterations of these
characters that you I don't really feel
like you need to conform to just this
one purpose if extort line that connects
all these movies do you're like
live-action Killing Joke film do your
you know Batman year one film it would
be cool to see them do like lower budget
films of these big characters because
part of the at least the magic for me
about comic books just as a medium is
that different artists and writers can
come in and put their spin on a
character and that's part of the magic
and sometimes it doesn't work and
sometimes it really does and you can
have multiple versions of a character
running at the same time yeah right now
we have the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that feels like Marvel but it seems like
a
nice time to start mixing in other
people's vibes that what it means to be
marvel is a broader spectrum or what a
speedy see is a broader spectrum yeah it
sucks so they're kind of just limiting
it to just that like this one specific
phase per every one of these films and
that'll help your your characters too
because then you're building franchises
in a more loose way just based on the
characters because the thing is it's
hard yeah when you're relying on the
same actor over and over to keep the
stakes always high and engaging there's
a reason Marvel kind of has a villain
yet problem is because every single time
has to be the biggest time yet and
there's only so many ways you can save
the world from all out complete
destruction yeah yeah so start telling
more focused you know contain the
stories within these universes yeah
exactly it doesn't sound like dcs any
plans to do like a Nightwing story if
you don't happen to know Nightwing what
is Dick Grayson after he was done being
roddney what's a Bludhaven or loot haven
I've never actually heard the
pronunciation of it I think it's
Bludhaven I think he's a very
fascinating character because he's a cop
I'd a vigilante at night so he's
constantly you know doing justice in the
world I think it'd be really cool if
they did like a lower budget doesn't
have to be like low budget below her
budget film where they have like some
other directors step and just do their
own take on it they don't feel like I
have to conform to keeping it tied into
the same universe or mentioning other
movies or something that's like this is
just its own standalone film I like to
see that especially with the kornberg
world cuz yet right currently I feel
like they're pretty limited on what they
can do and and then you get a lot of
people unsatisfied in the end well
because you do like there is a certain
conundrum about big you know really
expensive superhero movies that you have
to kind of check a certain number of
boxes and follow a certain structure
yeah cuz you have to field everybody at
that point because you need to make that
money back but if you look at something
like Deadpool if you take the best
lessons to be offered from Dead Poets
like you have this much lower budget
superhero movie that still manages to do
all the thrilling stuff but with a lot
of wackiness on fourth wall breaking and
personality and stuff and that's the
place for movies like these like I think
the best thing we learn from Deadpool is
that this kind of superhero movie also
works it's not just about being rated R
its oh this more esoteric thing works
just if we put it in the right scale I
feel like that would free something like
ghost rider up to be a little more
natural or something like jonah hex
could have been super cool a bit more
natural in an environment like that you
know me personally I I for the ever
since I read Batman year one many years
ago I've always wanted to see an
adaptation of it not where it's a part
of some bigger canon than the film
itself I think it would be cool if they
did a story just lieutenant Gordon that
featured Batman and you actually cut out
the stuff of Bruce Wayne or keep it but
keep some of it but don't ever make it
like known to the audience like let's
just say someone happens to come across
this Batman story that had no idea just
happened to not know that Bruce Wayne
and Batman of the same guy and the film
doesn't acknowledge that so sometimes
you see Bruce Wayne sometimes you see
Batman but you never see the movie go
there the same guy gags you know even
though as the audience we know that the
same guy but the film doesn't go out of
its way to say that to us you really
lock it into Gordon's perspex actly bad
that that that's my point of what I
would love to see a film do like some
random film doing I feel like I don't
feel like they lose money doing that or
if they would confuse audiences and a
big thing that I feel especially with DC
wanting to go down darker routes despite
whatever changes they're making now or
they're claiming they want to make them
much more light and heroic I feel like
if you wanted to go down your darker
routes this would be a great way to do
it this would be a great way to get your
r-rated comic book characters in there
cuz yeah the Deadpool is a great example
actually because even though yes it's
technically tied to the x-men the bigger
x-men universe it was a song like 50
million dollars right yeah it didn't
cost a lot of money to put together and
it came out amazing and a lot of to be
its own thing and I think they're
willing to go with an R rating because
it didn't cost too much money yeah yeah
exactly they were able to trial this
wacky [ __ ] out because you know enough
people raised their voices and it is
inexpensive enough so if we want to get
more unique comic book movies instead of
feeling like all these Marvel movies of
the Sandler all these DC moves are the
same it I could go into detail about how
they're not all are the same or whatever
and house another similar if we wanted
to get like are very very unique touches
or very you like get great filmmakers
who are who don't want to
part of huge studio films for the
specific reason that when they get
attached to do a comic book movie
they're like you got to follow sort of
things though because we got to keep it
tied to all these other films as well
here's creatively limit yeah they just
color it's like walking a lot of unable
we're gonna limit you go significantly
like if we want to egg her right to
actually do his own ant-man film and
gave him like a 50 million dollar budget
I feel like you could easily do that
yeah easily and it would be cool to just
get our own ant-man I don't feel like it
would be sitting there like pissed off
and confused and yeah it doesn't I yeah
and I mean and with that movie the stuff
that I feel like that movie could
improve upon is all stuff Edgar Wright
is great at yeah which kind of helps to
prove that point but I you know it's
like comics are a lot more than just
action adventure stories and I think
Marvel has done a decent job of
addressing that but it's still most of
the superhero comic book movies we see
right now our action adventure with
another genre mixed in and what would be
cool is to tip that balance where it's
more the other genre with some action
adventure elements because that's the
the cool thing that the success of shows
like walking dead and preacher or
showing us along with things like
Deadpool is that ahh like this stranger
less Hollywood blockbuster stuff also
works and that's something that people
might gravitate towards because you
don't want to see the same kind of thing
all the time yeah exactly no brandy
price I was back in Texas now that's why
she does ever come on the channel but
brandy price she has a short film that's
going around a lot of film festivals
getting a lot of praise called committed
and it's about Joker and Harley Quinn
she plays Harley Quinn of their in a
therapy session and it's cool because
I'm like this is just a low-budget film
like a really super indie film with a
joker and harley quinn it works for what
it is it really does work and i think
it'd be cool if studios at least allowed
filmmakers to do that you don't have to
exactly get Kevin Fahey involved and
have them do like a super strong like
involvement in their lower budget films
but it would be cool if they don't feel
like they have to conform to a bigger
canon than just a movie itself that also
give you a break from some of the
marketing things that people do complain
about like this sometimes awkwardly
incessant crossover thing and all that
and you know having to refer to other
movies having some self-contained things
will give people
better variety and it's nice to kind of
just focus on one movie at a time
sometimes yeah you know now that we know
the foreman now that we know the format
works and it's there now we can go look
at other stuff they're very talented
filmmakers who haven't had their chance
to take a shot at some of these
characters that they'd really do love I
know Nicholas Winton reffin was I forgot
what comic book hero he was going to be
adapting but he dropped out because he
said he didn't he didn't like the fact
of how limited he was yeah on what he
could do it I'm like yeah I've seen his
[ __ ] boobies there's no way he's
gonna do something that's conforming to
normality I would love to see some of
the more these artistic creative
directors have a chance at going I would
like to do my own Batman movie I don't
need this big of a budget cuz it's not
really about the huge action scenes yet
so you know like it'd be cool that I
would love to see that there are plenty
of more indie level or just more
mid-level guys with tons of style who
you would love to see at like if the guy
of Jeremy Sonia directed green room did
some kind of superhero movie that would
be [ __ ] crazy you know make it like a
really intense you know more gritty
story and then you get somebody like
you're right or like I would love to see
a winding reffin yeah great movie
because that would just be insanity and
there's tons to draw from in the 80s you
know that I feel you could get away with
it our ratings graphic novels it's
called graphic novels and a lot of them
are very graphic yeah and I would like
to see them like it would be cool to see
a lot more no holds bar kind of film
with a lot of our favorite superheroes
and such cuz that'll just free the
movies up to be what they are you know
if you know if you can bend John as you
can tell a story that's fitting and that
was what was so cool about that nerdy
hero videos that convinced me it was
like oh wow yeah if you did like a true
romance or a natural born killer style
movie but with Harley and the Joker that
would be bad yeah exactly but students
not gonna do that yeah it's like we
won't put 200 million dollar game are
not seen yeah yeah yeah what 30 videos
into that and get some good unknown
accurate or anything and just do it yeah
well there's someone out there can play
the Joker we knew that I can shoot it in
a month
yeah it happened like if you get guys
with all the resources in the world
managing something that's only 30
million dollars like just imagine how
great that little gem could be all right
guys outro subscribe is Instagram
Twitter handle listed their hairs become
real rejects bloom house social media
manager there let's give a shout to et
si woo et see these guys eat their own
[ __ ] stage forgot whoa in there they
forgot to put the O in the e-toc but
yeah that's who you guys are I'll go up
there we might be wondering why am i
insulting them I just I just wanted to
yeah what yeah what yo you guys only get
views because you get porn stars in your
videos oh that's right yeah I remember
that conversation we only get videos we
primarily go off other people's content
but okay